Now that you've seen all
the parts of a function,
let's put those pieces together.
We'll write a few function definitions
together and then call those functions.
We'll start with a description of the
task the function should accomplish, and
go from there.
Here's one you may have seen before.
Write a function that
takes in the string and
returns the first
character of that string.
Again we start with the func,
and then we need a name.
I'm going to call this
one firstCharacterOf.
I'll add my parentheses and
my curly braces.
In general,
don't shy away from long names,
especially in the age of code
completion, it's more important to be
descriptive than it is to save
yourself a few milliseconds of typing.
It also would have been fine to call
this function firstCharacter, but
I want to emphasize that the naming
convention in Objective C in Swift
is to use prepositions and function
names to refer to the first parameter.
In this case, a string.
Here this function is returning
the first character of
the string being passed in.
So we have our name.
Next comes the parameter
between parentheses.
Let's call the string we're
going to pass in, word.
That'll be its local parameter name.
And then we specify its type, string.
And next comes an arrow and
the return type.
Our return type in this case
is going to be character.
And I'm just going to write return "x"
here so that we can quiet that error for
the time being.
And finally we get to
the meat of the function.
In between curly braces here we'll put
the statements we want to execute.
There are a number of ways to get the
first character of a string in Swift.
I'm going to use subscript syntax
with the index start index.
And of course once we get that value,
we want to return it.
Okay, now it's time to call it.
firstCharacterOf is a global function,
so in order to call it,
we just write its name and then pass
in a parameter between parentheses.
And over here in the sidebar,
we can see that the first character
of Mom is being returned.
Now, notice that we didn't give
our parameter an external name,
we only gave it the local name, word.
Thus when we called it, we just
passed it in the parameter itself.
Let's go ahead and
add an external name to our parameter.
It's kind of hard to come up
with another word for word, so
I'm just going to use word again.
And now that we've specified
an external parameter name,
we need to use that external
parameter name in the function call.
Now you've probably noticed that the
compiler is complaining about something.
Let's see what it has to say.
Word word can be expressed
more succinctly as #word.
It wants us to use the shortcut for
external parameter names that
are the same as local parameter names.
If we just place a hash mark in front
of the local parameter name, we let
the compiler know that the external and
the local parameter names are the same.